ever like I'm gonna go and get a 1K
table like it's not image focused no
yeah I just
I just want to say something about black
people listen we're the strongest people
that ever existed on this planet like we
had Frederick Douglass who was a slave
who taught himself how to read and write
and had the people who hated him
paying him to go across the country and
tell them how bad slavery was we had the
Harlem Renaissance we had black men
going to Harvard in the 19th century
some of the best political philosophers
come from West Africa
come from the United States of America
we had a woman Rosa Parks that like like
some Doctor Strange stuff say you know
what I don't want segregation anymore
and just sat down
like you know you we really have to take
accountability for this because Haiti
defeated the French Empire like I I what
are you talking about like I mean these
are the craziest things that have
happened in history no lie no cap yeah
so how can we sit here and say that oh
we're we're weak or we're this over that
like if I mean like literally from a a
sign like a historical perspective the
things that we've done is unparalleled
so why do we think that we can't do
something we need to change this yes
racism is here but that never stopped us
and people were willing to die for it so
what are we willing to do now like so
racism exists but people were willing
not listening one more thing Malcolm X
convict criminal my guy went to Oxford
and debated in in the UK and debated
these people and had them respect him so
we can do literally anything so what
like we have to take accountability I'm
tired of hearing about the
yes racism is real 100 but we have to do
something like that
I mean it gets it gets to a point where
talking about what happened oh this this
is because of this bro like at the end
of the day as I said the internet's
there there's no excuse to be ignorant
you know there's uh forces working
against us we know that all this media
is deliberately working against us so
why do we keep fueling it now why do we
keep why do we keep why do we keep
glorifying the people like bro like
bro I didn't want to say people's names
but at the end of the day it's just like
if you're not a certain type of guy no
one doesn't care in our community and
what happens is a lot of guys that do
not fall into those certain categories
they feel alienated they feel like they
don't fit in the women are not
interested the women that they feel like
they qualify for don't feel like they're
good enough for them so then they go and
date outside and I've seen it bro I've
come I remember when I was in the states
I was in college bro I'm a big black guy
bro like and I'm from South East London
bro like I was born in King's College
Hospital anyone that knows knows brav
yeah but like I was told by a black
chick that I wasn't black enough
me you know
like and I was just like right and
listen I'm this is no disrespect to
anybody that you know has lived a
different type of like a black guy
that's lived a different type of life
because now I have the knowledge and I
understand that it doesn't because I
lived a rougher lifestyle doesn't make
me more black than the next man bro I
understand that at this at this stage in
development to get what I'm saying but
at the end of the day as a black guy
who's gone through all these kind of
rubbish trials and tribulations and
being indoctrinated to believe all this
crap about ourselves and everybody else
and then you come out the other's end of
it and then you try to make something of
your life and then some chick some black
girl comes and tells you you're not
black enough and oh I can only imagine
you being with a girl that's not black
that's very disheartening bro and that
will push you to go and do
go and do somebody else from outside
your race did she elaborate did she say
why
just film just the way I am just the way
I talk what did you say me
I don't know about that bro you all
right mate nah that's not that's what
I'm saying
he's not even trying to fit in on me in
it like you get what I'm saying like and
I just feel like a lot of guys feel like
they may not be allowed to just be
themselves do you get what I'm saying
like my guy here he's saying he likes
like other things that may be perceived
by a lot of black chicks as alternative
and not very desirable this is the real
thing like bro like when I talk to
there's there's times when I talk to
girls and listen I'm I'm very smart when
it comes to talking to girls I'm very
astute to know the things that girls are
not interested in RAV yeah which they
will find to be nerdy and uh that's
weird like your geek you know what I'm
saying and it kind of gets to a point
where it's like you can't even be
yourself whereas like
and I'm not again I'm not advocating for
IR dating I'm just saying my experience
I've come across non-black girls that
you know they'll see it as fun or funny
or something new to get into your
experience and it's just like why is it
that a lot of times our community is so
one-dimensional if you're not this thing
it's like you're weird and I and I don't
really
you know it's sad in it at the end of
the day gone yeah just to like
um connect it to that point I feel like
just a scenario so being in London
um I'm Portuguese I connect a lot with
like uh Spanish people Italian because
we have like similar cultures
um and I feel like maybe like connected
to what you're saying like you guys like
sorry I don't want to like anymore
because I'm not I'm not black but you
could as you were saying like you guys
can come together and instead of all
because I'm Nigerian and I'm Jamaican
I'm Ghanaian like you could come
together like I don't know what to say
like
yeah unified because at the end of the
day like I I I I don't have like many
Portuguese friends but I have a lot of
like Spanish and Italian friends and we
are not from the same country but
because we have similar cultures like we
kind of like come together so yeah just
to give a bit of an example sorry let me
let me let me just do the super chats
really really quickly are you gonna
bring them on the screen as well
all right cool let me run through the
Superstar and while I'm going through
the super chats please hit the like
button and add more Super Chats on top
RAV yeah we still now 300 300 likes here
you're not really doing me a disservice
I don't know what you're doing you're
just watching enjoying writing comments
you know dissing me this and everybody
you know what I mean and then boom just
sitting there bro do something yeah make
sure you support all right big up to
where we at where I'm reading some small
writing buff
um
we got to NSX for the Super Chat he says
question does clothing speech hair and
music help identify someone's culture or
is it skin color
I'll ask the Nova that question
um close hair and all that yeah it will
help clothing speech here and music my
mum's white but you definitely will know
she's angolan
so her culture is African what she looks
like has nothing to do with how she kind
of relates to her culture actually she's
blonde
so you're saying the skin color her like
the way she looks has nothing to do with
it uh not really it depends on where you
grow up but and that's why I say
sometimes interracial dating is not
about the race is more about the
cultural
you know links values as well yeah
principles habits absolutely all right
big up to
um the UK Economist for the super chai
says what your your feel what's your
female guest is actually saying is that
an educated black man has a high
standard that she is not accustomed to
and can't keep said gentlemen
um I guess he's talking to you still
he's definitely talking to me stone yeah
is that you baby UK Economist yeah UK
Economist said that to you from that's
good well you're gonna eat that yeah oh
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible